hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to project Murphy now much
like you I spend my Saturday's home
alone making some sick memes in
Photoshop and I thought to myself can I
have some robot do all this work for me
because I'm pathetic and ready for the
singularity to take over society and all
of us to be uploaded into the great
computer well look no further that time
is nigh because project Murphy is here
with Murphy bot to make all your meme
making and masturbating troubles go away
what I said mean making nothing else
you're weird I like that so the basic
principle is you ask Murphy bought a
question in a very specific way it's
like if Alex Trebek was a robot and
probably dead which is not as far as we
know so it goes a little something like
this if I was the type of message
what if Alex Trebek was a robot what is
oh i misspelled it I'm an idiot look at
that look how dumb I am
I'm very dumb do that what if what if
that thing I attacked what do we got oh
rumor has it then when Watson won
jeopardy it drove him steadily mad and
in an effort to be watching an ultrabook
decide to become a robot what if what if
head had has legs heads has leg it's a
little too mannequin knee for me I don't
know it's just too well done is the
problem its way well done it's his way
too well done Oh what if Sims were real
now that I spelled it right is this
gonna be correct that's again uh I
actually played this with Holly and Ross
on Holly's channel they introduced me to
the game in that oh boy if you want to
see that I believe they put up the first
video today I'll put a link in the
description but hoo boy we got a lot of
real madrid what if men were bikinis how
about some of that do you like that
better sure this doesn't appropriate
hang on a second upon closer inspection
I believe that this is just plain wrong
what if alien were bikinis I'm ready I'm
ready
nope no no no no no no ha ah that's
better
oh I'm super happy that I get to look at
that all day what if cars we're
businessmen give me some of that yeah I
don't know why it looks there's a shadow
on it why does it need to have a shadow
it just looks like this guy is having a
horrible face mask on him like he peeled
off someone's face and just slapped him
on himself give me something else
ah man still in the drop shadow but I
like that one that was good I like it
another it was a cushion down there
there was a cushion I was gonna add in
like a fake breaking sound effect
everybody ignore that that happened
pretend that I was cool and I pulled
that one off
that was a good face I like that face
that's a quality face grant of ideas
give up sad face
you failed me what if trains were people
give me some give me some good that's
all right
Oh Thomas they owe back Damon the
problem is it works really well like it
works - OH
what if trains were the moon you want
this staring down at your from oh oh my
god it's like a bad version of Majora's
Mask
I mean quote-unquote the good version
but the much worse version but if trains
were dogs ready for it oh god that's not
right
what did you do supposed to happen yeah
Oh God that poor dog it looks so cute I
smoked can you give me another attempt
to your Murph cuz woof that's out here's
an idea okay I'm ready
give me lay it on me why is the tongue
still got to be under there is this it
looks like a very vestigial beard or
like a neck ball sack I'm gonna give you
one more go at this if you can't get
this right holy
I mean it's better this is better
Murph this is better but it's so not
better
what if trains were markiplier ah that
didn't work out oh that's not her hey
he's got a beard he's got a very festive
beard one more go we'll see how it goes
ah what did you do what is that what is
that what is that am i turning into a
cyborg am i a terminator to have my face
get sheared off in an industrial
accident what's happening do I have a
parasitic twin on my face how about in a
more stupid way of phrasing this
question what if train was markiplier oh
that's oh that's that that's not right
oh that's not right Oh kill it with fire
Oh burn it in a pile Oh bury it and
covered it and cement and then put
sacrificial lambs on the grave so it
never Rises and haunts our dreams again
Oh kill that kill that dad I like it
give me another if you got one please
please tell me you got one oh yeah
Oh Oh juice not good that's not good
that is not good
whoo that's not good what it's small it
looks so horrifying one more come on you
got it in you come on please please
Murph hey Hayley you want somebody you
uh you wanna hang out with markiplier I
showed you promise look pretty correct
oh man all right what if train was Lord
minion seven seven seven I don't know if
it's gonna have one whoo it's got one oh
oh no oh no oh no oh no if you didn't
know that's the first picture of Wade
I've ever put online oh no oh no what if
train was my skirm well there's Bob who
is my skirm but he did it on the wrong
face I mean if this is what I got a my
cherished memories of our time in
colleges freshman year roommates I do
not remember being that hideously
handsome
he survived knowing that I just laid
awake at night with that face staring
over at him when he was sleeping I'll
give you one more crack at it there's
just one more oh that is amazing I love
that that is great
that is phenomenal I'm okay with that
please kill it please kill it daddy
please kill it I'm not okay with that
I was just I was masking my insecurities
with overconfidence that is horrible I
don't look at that anymore oh boy okay
okay I think I'm done I want everyone to
set this as their wallpaper please we've
got a whole bunch of nightmares sticking
with us for the rest of our lives I hope
we can eventually drink our problems
away but I can't drink so I'm screwed so
this was a bit of fun except for when it
got terrifying so that's project Murphy
if you enjoyed this let me know in
comments below if you want me to
photoshop anything a little better than
this let me know as well because I I
have a funny feeling I can do a
marginally better job but it is nice to
see the amalgamations of terror that it
conjures up from the depths of the
Internet so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye